l'ambassadeur du liban en france
souhaitent un cessez-le-feu imposé la
syrie par la force la france espère un
arrêt des combats par la voie
diplomatique au liban le canon ne s'est
pas arrêté là vendée sera cet été le
terrain d'expérimentation de la lutte
contre le sida le théâtre se met au
service des vacanciers formula le grand
prix de hongrie a été remportée par le
britannique nigel mansell sur ferrari
sénat second prost catria lorient
termine son 19e festival interceltique
les 4500 musiciens qui s'y sont produits
ont attiré 200 mille personnes en dix
jours mesdames mesdemoiselles messieurs
bonsoir on s'habitue peut-être un peu
trop entendre sur les médias que la
situation est critique à beyrouth qu'il
y a encore eu une vingtaine de morts
aujourd'hui que ce pays vit depuis
quinze ans dans la guerre parfois ce
sont des images qui nous font prendre
conscience de ce qu'endure la population
et notamment les enfants
bruno l'adresse
les derniers enfants de beyrouth depuis
quatre jours ils vivent dans une école
transformée en abri de fortune
ici on tente de les protéger de les
nourrir
dans la ville le pain manque l'eau
également quant à l'électricité il ya
longtemps qu'elle est coupée il ne reste
plus que les groupes électrogènes
si on trouve de l'essence pour les
alimenter depuis jeudi soir les
bombardements se poursuivent presque
sans discontinuer
la ville a perdu 85 % de ses habitants
partis se réfugier dans les zones moins
menacée ce matin le pilonnage a repris
dès 6 heures
or que de staline 40 projectiles à la
minute mortier de 180 et 120 mm un
torrent de feu comme l'a décrit un
beyrouth un des immeubles brûle pendant
plusieurs heures les pompiers ne peuvent
pas intervenir un enfer que les soldats
eux-mêmes redoute tout le monde a peur
explique celui ci
nous arrivons à un moment critique moi
même je suis un peu nerveux
selon des experts militaires occidentaux
il s'agirait là des plus violents
bombardements depuis 14 ans pour la
population
c'est encore un peu plus la mort qui
frappe au hasard
face à se mettre à cage les puissances
occidentales se décident d'intervenir
françois mitterrand qui s'est déclarée
très préoccupée du sort de tous les
libanais a demandé l'envoi de plusieurs
émissaires françois scherr secrétaire
général du quai d'orsay a rencontré
aujourd'hui quatre heures durant
le ministre syrien des affaires
étrangères jacques andréani directeur du
cabinet de roland dumas doit se rendre à
moscou
thierry tu bossais secrétaire d'état aux
affaires étrangères était ce matin au
maroc et se trouve actuellement en
algérie
alain decaux ministre de la francophonie
se rendra au vatican avant d'aller au
proche orient
et puis enfin l'ambassadeur de france à
washington doit saisir l'administration
américaine ainsi que le secrétaire
général de l'onu
commentaire du général aoun chef
chrétien du gouvernement libanais avec
la syrie at il déclaré aujourd'hui les
mots ou les considérations politiques ne
suffisent pas il faut prendre des
décisions dax
son armée semble d'ailleurs aujourd'hui
très menacé les syriens ont lancé une
vaste offensive terrestre pour tenter de
prendre sous qu'elle garde le verrou qui
contrôle l'entrée sud de l'enclavé
chrétienne il semblerait ce soir que la
8e brigade
les troupes d'élite de l'armée libanaise
et repousser l'assaut mais dans le cas
contraire c'est la route sur la
résidence du général aoun et sur
beyrouth est qu'ils seraient ouverts
l'ambassadeur du liban à paris pense que
la diplomatie est dépassé il souhaite un
cessez-le-feu imposé par la force
le pape a annoncé aujourd'hui que la
prière de la fête de l'assomption
seraient consacrés au peuple libanais
qui souffrent aux etats-unis le
président george bush a voulu faire de
ce dimanche une journée de prière pour
les otages occidentaux détenus au liban
sur place à washington
jean-marc il use ce dimanche de prière
demandée par le président bush n'a pas
été à washington en tout cas l'occasion
de manifestations organisées mais chacun
les paroissiens qui se recueillaient ici
ce matin dans la grande cathédrale nous
a dit être venu avec une pensée pour les
otages américains du liban je vais prier
pour tous les otages des deux côtés ce
pas seulement les otages américains
je crois que le moment est venu de se
parler de se réconcilier
cela sera profitable aux uns comme aux
autres carter et regan se sont fait
piéger dans un contexte où il ne pouvait
jouer lui dans un sens ni dans l'autre
je crois que bush lui a plus de
possibilités d'action je crois que cette
fois ci les dirigeants iraniens veulent
bien nous aider et qu'on peut
sérieusement espérer
auriez-vous que les otages pourront être
libéré bientôt
non pas du tout il faudra du temps les
décisions de politique étrangère pas
facile à prendre
se servir de la force non on se fera
plaisir
il y aura d'autres prises d'otages tout
ça va prendre du temps
tout se passe désormais comme si les
américains ne se faisait guère en
matière de libération d'otages de
grandes illusions ceux qui sont
partisans de la diplomatie ils sont une
petite majorité comme ceux de la
minorité bruyante qui périodiquement
réclame une action punitive
personne donc datant de miracles du
président bush mais chacun lui sait gré
d'avoir déjà su obtenir un sursis
le président bush qui s'efforce d'éviter
toute dramatisation excessive
mercredi prochain il partira comme prévu
dans sa résidence de nouvelle angleterre
à deux heures d'avion washington hier
c'était les protestants qui
manifestaient dans les rues de
londonderry aujourd'hui ce sont les
catholiques à belfast ils ont commencé à
manifester contre l'arrivée des troupes
britanniques en irlande du nord demain
il y aura tout juste 20 ans jérôme
bonnet
après la prestation des protestants hier
à derry ce sont aujourd'hui les
catholiques à belfast qui ont la vedette
avec leurs parades démonstration sens
fifres et tambours sont également au
rendez-vous mais eux servent
contrairement aux protestants une pause
républicaine et anti britannique
ici la plupart des uniformes sont vert
aux couleurs de la république d'irlande
à laquelle il voudrait voir l'irlande du
nord
rattaché le style est parfois carrément
paramilitaires m il ira si les musiciens
à la gloire de l'armée républicaine
irlandaise qui combat l'armée
britannique dans la clandestinité
ils sont venus de toute l'irlande et
même des cosses cette année pour cette
parade qui tombe la veille du 20e
anniversaire de l'intervention des
troupes britanniques
le 14 août 1969 les forces de sécurité
sont sur le qui vive
le chef de la police d'ulster a lui même
fait le déplacement
lui aussi doit calmer ses troupes la
police donne ces derniers temps des
signes de nervosité
ce photographe français l'a appris à ses
dépens alors qu'ils faisaient un
reportage sur un accrochage nocturne
meilleurs à la parade protestante il ya
aussi des chances de figurer dans la
situation a évolué depuis dix ans les
différents n'aurait pas imaginé les
militaires britanniques aussi près des
manifestants mais dans le questionnement
les habitants du quartier nous
comprenons que la haine est toujours
aussi que rien ici c'est l'irlande
expliquent sur les publics
les français feront la loi pour les
français pourra nous voulons que les
irlandais fasse la loi pour nous ne
voulons pas qu'un homme ou une femme
anglais nous dise ce que nous avons à
faire ou à ne pas faire parade militante
et politique avec le martyrologe de
l'armée clandestine
c'est plus tard dans la soirée que tout
peut arriver
cette nuit les patrouilles britannique
et paul ansel de la police seront encore
une fois sur le pied de guerre
la navette columbia parts il y a cinq
jours pour une mission militaire ultra
secrète s'est posée aujourd'hui sur la
base d'edwards en californie
l'approché et l'atterrissage n'ont posé
aucun problème mais cette fois le public
n'a pas assisté au retour secret oblige
on sait cependant qu'un satellite espion
de 10 tonnes a été placé en orbite
il permettra notamment ce satellite de
surveiller les soviétiques et de
vérifier s'ils se conforment bien au
traité de désarmement
le satellite hipparcos destiné à
observer les astres lui ne va pas très
bien
n'a toujours pas atteint son orbite
géostationnaire un moteur refuse
toujours de fonctionner les
scientifiques n'ont cependant pas dit
leur dernier mot
il cherche toujours à trouver une
solution pour le faire remonter le seul
moyen d'éviter le sida on sait c'est la
prévention en vendait une troupe
théâtrale a reçu pour mission de
sensibiliser le public elles seront là
où se trouvent les vacanciers c'est à
dire tout près des plages nathalie dollé
et daniel lévy partout ils nous servent
sauf que nous nous voyons en silence en
amont il faut il sape il déchire et syna
transfair l'autre l'objet de nos voeux
en meurtrier possible celui qui est
inconscient devient véhicules morbide
tout cela nous le savons mais nous
restons immobiles
une comédie pour éviter le drame pendant
l'été la campagne anti sida se déplace
sur les coups de vent
n une pièce de théâtre qui ne détourne
les plagistes qu'un petit quart d'heure
juste le temps de rappeler que le sida
lui ne prend jamais de vacances
elle n'est pas venue travailler ces
jours ci elle est malade c'est grave
très grave mais c'était juste une fille
gentille merde j'ai baisé avec elle
après le spectacle des comédiens une
troupe de spécialistes médicaux prend le
relais discussions précision un dialogue
informel avec le public pour rappeler
que seule la prévention du sida et
efficace après il est trop tard alors on
n'a pas de leçon de morale à venait mais
il faut que les gens se responsabilisent
par eux-mêmes qu'ils comprennent très
bien l'enjeu qu'elle prendrait aucun
risque c'est le préservatif
sinon rien
pour cette deuxième année le spectacle a
bien évolué il intègre les dernières
données sur le sida et insiste
dorénavant beaucoup plus sur le mode
d'emploi du préservatif ou sur la notion
de fidélité une pièce de théâtre donc
joué par des professionnels est écrite
en étroite collaboration avec les
autorités sanitaires
on m'a demandé de parler un peu plus de
la relation longue durée et donc c'est
pour ça que voyez un spectacle qui parle
de la relation de longue durée ce qui
n'est pas forcément ma philosophie ma
manière de pensée personnelle et je me
suis plié aux directives comme qu'on me
demandait c'est une commande si je suis
apte à je peux transmettre à claire est
clair
seul m bah non c'est justement ce monde
est concerné donc vous utilisez des
préservatifs régulièrement plus long
possible
toujours au bord de la mer la
construction du pont de l'île de ré vous
en souvenez avait soulevé d'importantes
polémiques même le commandant cousteau
s'en était mêlée va sans gerard c'est
patrick gabet sont allés voir sur place
comment hal usage réagissait la
population est aussi ce qui avait changé
vous allez voir il ya des surprises
le pont côté il avec un homme plus au
comptant il s'appelle jean pierre
lévesque des ostréiculteurs et comme
tous ses collègues grâce au pont depuis
un an il fait des économies
on économise pratiquement une heure
sinon plus à chaque voyage c'est à dire
que tant qu'on passe sur l'entreprise au
lieu de passer leurs attentes dans le
véhicule ça se traduit forcément
l'argent
plus de facilités pour la vie de tous
les jours des îliens le fonds a comme
prévu a mené aussi beaucoup de gens de
passage sur l'île ce qui fait marcher le
commerce
toute l'année on s'arrête dans les
villages pour acheter des souvenirs des
cartes postales l'écart s'arrête dans
les restaurants pour prendre le repas
oui lessard c'est hors saison en
revanche on s'attendait à des records
d'affluence cet été avec des touristes
dans tous les coins de l'île eh bien
surprise il y en a eu moins que prévu
un peu moins en juillet les charmants
plus en août mais le phénomène pont à
mon sens commencent à s'estomper il ya
une grande curiosité en 1988 un peu
moins en 1989 est vraisemblablement
encore un peu moins en 91
mais il n'ya pas que les touristes avec
le fond lille et ses charmantes ce site
maison est devenue la banlieue préférée
des gens du continent les prix ont
grimpé
il ya eu certainement un phénomène
d'anticipation avant la construction du
pont et puis aussi je pense à phénomène
de rattrapage
résultat aujourd'hui le prix du mètre
carré a doublé les prix dans dans les
terrains bâtir que dans le secteur
construits sont à peu près au niveau de
ce qui se pratique sur le continent
les maisons poussent comme des
champignons les 20% des espaces
constructibles de l'île seront bâtis
dans dix ans soit trois fois plus vite
que prévu la preuve les permis de
construire près de 500 accordé en 88
chiffre jamais atteint auparavant et
déjà plus de trois cents pour le premier
trimestre 89
il ya une augmentation considérable de
crédit foncier ce qui est très très
mauvais oeil une surchauffe au niveau du
foncier et il ya également donc un
emballement de la construction donc
immobilière ce qui n'est pas bon du tout
pour l'île de ré les constructions
abusives guette le sud de l'île au nord
ici c'est en une vaste zone hui très
fragile peuplé d'oiseaux
elle devait être sérieusement protéger
devant la multiplication des passages et
un an après la mise en service du pont
ce n'est toujours pas le cas des
promesses n'ont pas été tenues
on
devait notamment avoir une extension de
la reverb pour préserver ce site qui est
unique en europe indispensable aux
oiseaux migrateurs particulièrement pour
le préserver de l'invasion des touristes
auraient devait y avoir une extension
avec une autre réserve à côté n'existe
toujours pas personne ne conteste plus
les facilités apportée par le pont les
antilles puntistes comme on dit ici
veulent en revanche tout faire pour
éviter les abus et les excès de
l'immobilier encore on savait les
anglais grand amateur de limousin et de
dordogne à présent ceux qui jouent à
fond la carte de l'europe choisissent de
s'installer au moins pour les vacances
dans le jardin de la france la touraine
les habitants de la région n'y trouve
rien à redire et les agents immobiliers
se frotte les mains valérie fourniau et
pierre szysz au sergent au pays du
rabelais et de belzec
le chinon devient grit le chèvre fait
aucune hérésie les onglets sont
connaisseurs
après avoir écumé le périgord goûter la
cuisine française
ce sont maintenant des endroits comme
celui ci qui les attire
la touraine ses cadres et ses maisons en
pierres de tuffeau
la maison est moins cher pour les
anglais c'est très bon deux cent mille
francs une affaire même s'il ya eu
quelques travaux effectués j'ai eu pas
mal de travail j'ai tour chez moi même
du sol jusqu'au plafond
autour de chinon les acquisitions faites
par les anglais représentent jusqu'à 40%
des ventes
et depuis un an le phénomène s'accentue
fort de leur pouvoir d'achat ils
investissent dans la pierre de taille
entre 150 et 250 mille francs pour une
résidence secondaire
au dessus c'est pour y vivre heureux
qu'elle ait fait
un minimum de sanitaires et là ils sont
heureux ils achètent pratiquement tous
combien de visiter une propriété avec
des français et chez le notaire on a
retrouvé des anglais qui venait
s'intéresser également d'ailleurs ses
propriétés et je pense qu'il va y avoir
pas mal dit long de l'évolution des prix
peut être à craindre de par la règle
effectivement des anglais et les
français sont ravis d'être débarrassé de
ses maisons boudé depuis des années par
les parisiens l'anglais la providence
les prix grimpent rares sont ceux qui
n'ont pas fait une affaire en leur
vendant une maison y avait pas de
sanitaire et j'ai trouvé qu'elle était
vendu pas mal d'ailleurs
elle était lui il n'a trouvé qu'il avait
bien vendu de l'immobilier encore on
savait les anglais grand amateur de
limousin et de dordogne à présent ceux
qui jouent à fond la carte de l'europe
choisissent de s'installer au moins pour
les vacances dans le jardin de la france
la touraine les habitants de la région
n'y trouve rien à redire et les agents
immobiliers se frotte les mains valérie
fournier et pierre szysz au sergent au
pays de rabelais et de belzec
le chinon devient grit le chèvre m 8o
qu'une hérésie les onglets sont
connaisseurs
après avoir écumé le périgord goûter la
cuisine française
ce sont maintenant des endroits comme
celui ci qui les attire
la touraine ses caves et ses maisons en
pierres de tuffeau
le maison est moins cher pour les
anglais c'est très bon deux cent mille
francs une affaire même s'il ya eu
quelques travaux à effectuer
j'ai eu pas mal de travail
j'ai tout refait moi-même du sol
jusqu'au plafond autour de chinon les
acquisitions faites par les anglais
représentent jusqu'à 40% des ventes
et depuis un an le phénomène s'accentue
forts de leur pouvoir d'achat ils
investissent dans la pierre de taille
entre 150 et 250 mille francs pour une
résidence secondaire
au dessus c'est pour y vivre avec elle à
l'adresse ip
un minimum de sanitaires et là ils sont
heureux ils achètent pratiquement tous
pour le bien de visiter une propriété
avec des français est il chez le notaire
on a retrouvé des anglais qui y venaient
s'intéresser également d'ailleurs cette
propriété et je pense qu'il va y avoir
pas mal disons de l'évolution des prix
peut-être à craindre de par la rive
effectivement des anglais et les
français sont ravis d'être débarrassé de
ses maisons boudé depuis des années par
les parisiens l'anglais la providence
les prix grimpent rares sont ceux qui
n'ont pas fait une affaire en leur
vendant une maison y avait pas de
sanitaires et j'ai trouvé qu'elle était
mort ligne pas mal d'ailleurs
elle était à lui trouvé ça très gentil
depuis deux ans payé team troque les
foudres de bristol pour un été sans
brouillard la chaleur d'une tour india
mais que young en charente maritime les
gendarmes ont pris le relais de la
grogne ils ont été suivis par ceux de
gironde ils dénoncent eux aussi leurs
conditions de vie et de travail dans le
vaucluse un incendie criminel a été
maîtrisé il a fallu y mettre les moyens
pour le maîtriser cet incendie cinq
canadair se sont portés sur les lieux
deux tracker et 18 véhicules incendie
qui a menacé plusieurs maisons avaient
été allumés volontairement trois
hectares ont brûlé
l'incendiaire n'a pas été arrêté au
brésil
un fait divers tient en haleine le pays
tout entier depuis pratiquement le début
du mois quatre gangsters ont enlevé un
enfant
ils ont ensuite accepté de l'échanger
contre trois adultes ce qu'ils veulent
maintenant c'est qu'on leur fournisse
les moyens de quitter le pays pour le
paraguay
pour le moment ils sont immobilisés sur
une route à 600 km de sao paulo and gas
burget depuis cinq jours elle vit avec
cette arme
constamment braqués sur elle à bout de
forces terrorisé les trois otages du
camion blindé ont vu cette nuit encore
une fois la liberté leur échapper un
cauchemar qui n'en finit pas pour ces
deux jeunes femmes journalistes à la
télévision brésilienne et le conducteur
du camion l'impasse depuis qu'ils ont
accepté le 9 août dernier des traits
changer contre sept enfants saïd agel
philo neuf ans enlevé une semaine
auparavant à goiana impasse encore hier
soir lorsque contre toute attente les
ravisseurs de couples mariés ont refusé
le marché proposé par les autorités les
négociations semblent pourtant aboutir
car les ravisseurs avaient enfin accepté
de libérer leurs otages en échange d'un
avion à destination du paraguay avion
qui gêné par l'obscurité n'a pu se poser
sur la route et dû rebrousser chemin
toute négociation ont alors été rompues
le camion blindé à bout de course cerné
par une centaine de policiers et ce soir
toujours immobilisé près de la ville de
préside nt 'prudent' et à 600 km au
nord-ouest de sao paulo sport le grand
prix de hongrie il a été remportée ni
par senna ni par prost mais par un
outsider nigel mansell sur ferrari le
brésilien se classe second et le
français doit se contenter de la
quatrième place résumé de la course
lionel chamoulaud le grand moment du
concile sanguinaire ayrton senna est en
tête nigel mansell et dans ses roues
mécénat est bloqué par le mix de stefan
johansson et mansell remarquable
d'opportunisme surprend le brésilien
grâce à une manoeuvre fantastique
à la suite de ce dépassement mm la
ferrari s'envole mais quelle émotion
il faut savoir être très opportuniste
c'est à dire être bien placé au bon
moment pour pouvoir saisir la plus
petite possibilité mais bien sûr dans
une telle manoeuvre
c'est aussi une question de chance et là
j'ai eu de la chance de la chance et
aussi du panache pour la première fois
de la saison mclaren est battu à la
régulière
senna est deuxième alain prost lui fini
à la quatrième place
les mclaren déjà dominé aux essais par
riccardo patrese l'italien malheureux
qui a été leader pendant les deux tiers
de la course avant que son moteur ne
casse
quinzième succès pour nigel mansell le
deuxième de l'année le britannique se
place 3e du championnat du monde
prost est toujours leader avec 14 points
d'avancé sur senna après ce grand prix
de hongrie
on retiendra que les mclaren sont
prenables sur certains circuits
bravo ferrari bravo mansell pour le
grand prix de suède motocyclistes c'est
l'américain eddie lawson qui remporte
l'épreuve en 5 centimètres cubes selon
le français christian sarron thierry
blancot pour les résultats tout avait
bien commencé pour le leader du
championnat du monde wayne rainey départ
hyper rapide devant lawson schwantz
aaron et mackenzie piste a séché après
deux jours d'essai sous la pluie pluie
de records du tour après lawson sarron
pulvérise les chronos mais le duel c'est
entre rennes et numéro trois et lawson
numéro 1 24 tours roue dans roue après
la chute de rennais à deux tours de la
fin lawson s'envole cavalier seul pour
une quatrième victoire en suède et la
tête du classement mondial
sarr on termine deuxième wine garner
pour son retour troisième le championnat
du monde est relancé
performance en sitka victoire de
l'équipage suisse bilan valtice berg un
équipage français sur le podium
le side de michel et fresques se classe
deuxième
tout juste devant les britanniques
webster et lyon 8 webster et hewitt qui
sont en tête du classement mondial
comme si le titre mondial qu'il a d'ores
et déjà qu'ils ne nous suffisait pas
sito pons remporte une septième victoire
cette saison en grand prix course
prudente et régulière pons s'impose
devant roth cornu et kargus
les championnats de france d'athlétisme
se dispute à tous aujourd'hui le record
de france du 100 m dames a été battu par
laurence bini qui a battu son propre
record 11 secondes et 400e admirions
formidable laurence bily ch
au couloir 4 la nouvelle recorman de
france du 100 m en 11 secondes quatre
centièmes
on se demande 400e 10 centièmes de mieux
que son propre record établi il y à un
mois
meilleur temps de réaction est jeune
nous faut terry pour la doubler et après
ça tous les autres courses le 200 mètres
et la bagarre entre trois copains sans
ghouma morinière et marie rose en vert
au 4ème couloir
le titre pour marie rose en 10 secondes
16 centièmes
malheureusement bon je me suis fait mal
un peu trop pataud dans la course et je
pense que j'aurais pu aller un petit peu
plus vite encore ce qui prouve que je me
mange charbon à mon meilleur niveau même
un peu meilleures et les tribulations
cette manne augure pour la suite des
compétitions et marie-rose nouveau voir
disputer français
pour le tiercé qui se courait cet après
midi à deauville il fallait jouer le
dise le 12 et le 17 qui rapporte pour 5
francs dans l'ordre 3107 francs et 50
centimes et dans un ordre différent 621
francs est toujours 50 centimes pour le
quarté il fallait ajouter las ils
rapportent dans l'ordre pour 6 francs 32
1546 francs et 40 centimes dans un ordre
différent 2559 francs et 60 centimes le
19e festival interceltique de lorient se
termine sur un succès en dix jours deux
cent mille personnes sont venues
entendre jouer de la bombarde et du
biniou
la fête s'est terminée par la nuit du
port de pêche au son des cornemuses bien
entendu les eaux lamberton et michel
jeannot latos y était voyage au pays des
scènes l'ami du port de cloche a
commencé très tôt au son des guitares
sait qu en humus qui viennent du
nord-ouest de l'espagne de galice le
festival c'est avant tout une
gigantesque fête de famille entre
cousins la nuit tombée près de trente
mille personnes se bousculent avenue de
la perrière la grande fête populaire qui
clôture traditionnellement le festival
bat son plein jusqu'à l'aude
une quarantaine de groupes à faire
danser et rêver la cité morbihannaise
comme ce voyage en irlande proposé par
les bars salles
de l'espagne à l'irlande en passant par
l'écossé la bretagne ils sont venus du
vision différente en tournée un ami
à nîmes qui chante l'histoire de ce
peuple le petit cinq siècles avant
jésus-christ dominer l'europe et que les
romains ont repoussés vers l'ouest
mais au fait comment dit on quand on est
celle où comment je crois qu'on a des
traditions
en 19 ans d'existence le festival à
crisser propre vedette enfants chéris
des lorientais les jumbo jet avec eux
c'est toute la tradition du chant marin
qui revient
lancée en 1971 par un groupe de
passionnés du folklore régional
le festival interceltique est passé de
30 milles à 200000 spectateurs une
affluence record pour un festival
français
dès le départ les organisateurs ont
refusé de se confiner dans le passé et
lorient a accueilli des groupes de rock
de jazz pour risque d'en dérouter
certains milieux
je ne mens pas un peu pouvaient rangs
permettant dans un ghetto et d'exprimer
au contrat vous avez un maximum de
fenêtres pour d'un côté s'apercevoir de
ce que font les autres et puis de dire
aux autres regardez ce que nous faisons
oh
à lorient on ne fait pas de confronter
des cultures différentes
on essaie aussi de faire un bout de
chemin ensemble one d'orgue de cette
ouverture
lavaud devenir l'antichambre des vies
près d'un voyage le mariage réussi
une cornemuse irlandaise et un orchestre
classique
musique en pleine évolution la musique
celte elle est assurément
reste à savoir quand les amarres avec la
tradition elle ne risque pas de vauvert
à la dérive
au bo
ce journal est à présent terminée je
vous remercie de l'avoir suivi dans
quelques secondes and ponsinet vous dira
tout sur la météo
votre prochain rendez vous avec
l'information c'est rémy roche autour de
minuit
je vous retrouverai demain à 13h et
philippe lefait vous présentera le
journal de 20 heures en attendant passé
une très bonne soirée sur antenne 2
merci